when we look at the next chart we've got
bitcoin is on pace to settle 45 trillion
in 2021 totaling twice as much value as
all of his previous years combined that
is an insane number yeah so this is a
chart from you seeing that at arc they
put out great stuff
and this is just kind of this is going
into more of the medium of exchange
aspect of it right so everyone gets
store value you can buy bitcoin you can
you can leave it on coinbase or you can
send it to your cold storage and you can
sit there and watch it and and it's a
pretty strong bet over time that it'll
increase your purchasing power
just due to the absolute scarcity of it
and due to the adoption curve and more
and more people coming to this asset
class because of those properties right
but most people or you know less than
the amount of people that understand the
story value side don't really you know
the the medium of exchange or maybe the
settlement aspect of bitcoin is very
underappreciated so this network in a
completely apolitical sovereign way
where there's there's no ceo there's no
board there's no uh there's really
there's no off switch right china just
picked up and you know 50 of the network
was forced to to shut off overnight uh
and bitcoin kept on chugging right so
you know 45 trillion dollars or on pace
for that in in 2021 um it's a pretty
insane number and so uh you know you're
you're doubling or i'm sorry yeah
doubling visa i believe uh and and
that's you know
pretty different when you're looking at
settlement assurances but say the best
comparison is fed wire well that's you
know we're already six percent of the
way there compared to fedwire and so i
wouldn't bet on this trend uh stopping
anytime soon uh and you know that kind
of supports the more medium of exchange
aspect to it there's you know final
settlement all over the world 24 7 365.
yeah it's pretty incredible uh bitcoin
the cumulative network transfer volume
22.2 uh 22.6
trillion as of 1221. uh which is uh
today
yeah so that's the first chart show just
total volume and this one um i should
have labeled it a little better shows
change adjusted transfer volume so the
bitcoin utxo set when say you have one
bitcoin and you send 0.5
well i send 0.5 to you pomp and 0.5
bitcoin goes back to me and that's
that's a change that's uh you like
change for the utxo and so technically
change adjusted volume just filters out
that 0.5 bitcoin i sent back to to
myself um just that's how bitcoin
transactions work um and so over the
course of its history um bitcoin is has
done 22.6 trillion dollars of change
adjusted volume um and that's you know
obviously hockey sticking up and to the
right and so i just kind of shows you
that you know this protocol is
continuing to grow and in terms of
medium exchange it's a lot bigger and
does a lot more value than people think
which means that bitcoin in 2021 has
done over 10 trillion right so you know
about 10 to 12 trillion of this about
half of it was done this year in 2021
compared to what it's done since its
beginning of its life
yep correct it's pretty insane yeah
absolutely nuts and and uh i don't know
the exact visa uh settlement number but
i do believe that uh visa's annual
transaction volume
is now
right around what bitcoins is like
they're they're much closer than you
would think right i think that visa if i
remember correctly is somewhere in the
like 14 to 16 uh
trillion number and obviously bitcoin
being at let's call it 12 or so uh
hasn't quite eclipsed it yet but uh but
we're getting pretty damn close
yeah and i think a lot of people it
should be to be said that you know
comparing visa to bitcoin it's
definitely um a cool kind of comparison
and a milestone but just in terms of
settlement assurances and final and you
know just
yeah settlement finality um it's a lot
different right swiping my car to visa
basically they have an internal ledger
and they just they just debit someone
and basically just change the ledger a
little bit but it can be changed uh
pretty easily there's there's no final
settlement for sometimes you know weeks
or months on end um and at the end of at
the end of whatever period that is the
bank and and visa will you know transfer
over
you know billions of dollars and kind of
that's the final settlement but when
people are comparing you say a 10 minute
bitcoin transaction or bitcoin blocks to
visa it's definitely the wrong
comparison i think that next this next
chart that will show as more apples to
apples